Parece que la presión de los titulares
de prensa nacional e internacionales
está surtiendo efecto en el caso de los
insultos a vinicius en España Este
martes la Policía Nacional anunció la
detención de tres jóvenes españoles de
entre 18 y 20 años en Valencia como
presunto responsables de los gritos
racistas al jugador brasileño del Real
Madrid el domingo pasado cuando jugaban
un partido de la liga en el campo de
mestalla a los detenidos que han sido
puestos en libertad tras sus
declaraciones tendrán que presentarse en
caso de ser reclamados por la policía
que sigue investigando el caso que
podría clasificar como un delito de odio
hoy mismo también ha sido arrestados
otros cuatro hombres por estar
involucrados en otro incidente distinto
pero también racista contra el mismo
vinicius en Madrid en enero cuando iban
a jugar un partido de la Copa del Rey
contra el Atlético de Madrid En esa
ocasión los jóvenes detenidos
presuntamente colocaron una muñeca
hinchable con la camiseta del brasileño
colgando desde el cuello de un puente
cerca de la Ciudad Deportiva del equipo
blanco estos jóvenes de entre 19 y 24
años también podrían ser acusados de
delitos de odio el consejo superior de
deportes español comunicó que pondrá en
marcha una campaña contra el racismo en
los campos de fútbol en colaboración con
la liga y la federación española de